yeah hello there welcome to this
broadcast I hope I'm real life as usual
I got my doubts so someone from the chat
please give me a short notice if I'm
really live would be great yeah been a
very hectic day so i hope i hope i've
got everything set up correctly so
anybody around in the chat i guess
people are busy watching the scene for a
couple i'm still doing doing that show
okay i'm going to play a couple of blitz
games here they haven't played a single
game of chess today so really have to
get into the thick of things yeah
someone confirmed that i'm life that's
cool so let's get going i'm requesting a
game and oh I got one key one I think
it's key right key one so I've played
him a couple of times I don't really
don't really remember nine games oh wow
okay so we got a queen's gambit so let's
see the semi tirage okay go play with g3
a.m. I don't really have a great reply
to the sabotage I have to admit mmm
that'd be six cents an interesting move
putting pressure on deform Bishop e3 is
maybe nights you form a tick on c5 it
will take on d1 Joe maybe anyway
white some main claim for any advantage
I mean if there is any it will be small
is based on this bishop on g2 but this
is in fact a good reply Bishop will come
to e6 probably so I'm going to unmask my
bishop may be putting something on c4
there should be six however as a very
likely reply no didn't do it okay but 94
now looks okay threatening 96 and if he
takes this is some a little bit more
comfortable for white I guess nothing in
particular but should be maybe a little
something I think our castle anyway
threatening bishops is six winning a 10
point in a way up here from 96 193 and
then checks I don't know what is what is
he playing rook the eighth or something
96 m looks annoying then well I like
that position it should be slightly
better for white maybe yeah I haven't
looked at the sink filled cup games of
tonight didn't get anything didn't get
to watch anything because I've been busy
yeah if you saw my announcement video on
my channel where I said I wouldn't want
to go on camera because I looked kind of
out of thoughts was because I'm a simple
thing actually I bought a relatively
small piece of furniture um I am or at
ikea you know that that Swedish
furniture company and you have to build
it on your own right and
yeah it was it was hell yeah it was a it
took me almost three hours to piece
everything together and it's not because
I made any mistakes while building it it
was just terribly complicated yeah
someone says the late announcement has
something with the lack of to do with
the lack of people the thing is to be
honest I don't really see why I need to
announce it every week people i mean it
is it is on every week anyway so why do
I have to make a video every week
actually I was thinking of posting
something in regards that I'm stopping
that because it's pretty useless it's
just like I mean you you have your
favorite TV series that you don't need
to check the check the magazine or
website every week if it is really on at
the same time every week but well some
people seem to rely on that that
announcement okay so I'm going to take
here and this is an interesting question
take on c6 or not that can be can be
tricky business his pawn structure is
weakened but that I don't want to do
that my light squared um weaknesses then
I would be so pronounced okay well here
I cannot take but I can retreat that
night maybe get that into the picture
with 92 yeah maybe maybe do that
yeah someone said that they didn't like
the sink filled cup coverage I think
it's um it's the usual um team that if
San Luis is doing doing a broadcast and
usually I think they do have a decent
job ok so I'm playing at for gaining
some space there and allowing my king to
be activated it is some equal this
position I guess ok maybe before now and
his night is a little bit a little bit
of them they're not really it's nothing
nothing to do much with now you can come
to do six rather equal ish but I don't
mind that somewhat slow start of this
broadcast because as I said that's
what's been tough building that that
bloody piece of furniture so maybe just
go backward mm-hmm
now I'm not kind of commentating the
same field cut burn tonight there are
other people doing that so I'm not
getting not doing them the same thing as
other people do I mean I CCS doing
coverage if you are member there and of
course there's the official broadcast by
the local team as it was mentioned with
was just Sarah one and Maurice Ashley
yeah this is an equal end game but I can
offer a draw here maybe maybe it take
that it's not very exciting anyway yeah
he took it it wasn't a very exciting
game but it might be more interesting
later on yeah I'm mum other said pretty
much exhausted drop from three hours
with that bloody instruction manual to
build that thing I don't even know how
it is called in english and german we
have a name for that it's called comoda
it's a thing with with to draw a center
a little thing that you put beside your
bed it looks very simple but it still
has 51 steps to build um I'm requesting
a new game but things are relatively
slow going now i'm going to player one
more game and maybe look look briefly at
the sinclair cup games because i'm
simply i'm interested myself how Adam is
some developing first round was a very
spectacular no draw at all cool stuff
okay utah alpha mu is the component and
so let's get this Owen in the road primo
c4 okay again yeah let's do primos ok
I'm going forward tomorrow off nope
Queen c7 pre-move that would be rather
forthcoming if not be five is played and
someone says the camera to pile of is
interesting okay so we should be towards
a slowish continuation Oh Quincy 7i
guess staying within the tomorrow okay i
can go d 6 or something like that but
why not stay within that territory here
white normally goes here this or king h1
and Bishop before that is one point of
the whole thing that black can develop
that Bishop and put some pressure on the
e4 pawn it's quite funny that the main
line of this opening is actually um yeah
now I know now night a force the main
line recently I saw queen d 4 and
supposed to be interesting but haven't
checked it in much detail I just saw ok
this is a move haha but I didn't didn't
study it if he goes Queen D for what am
I actually playing no it doesn't yeah
castling can hardly be wrong yeah hello
okay I'm going pushing t5 yet put some
steak some claim in the center and the
Queen on d3 i'm not sure about I've got
a five and possibly Bishop a six coming
unless playing against greece okay i
already have to check after after this
broadcast maybe after there's this game
yeah he's taking a while there I don't
know what exactly is thinking about when
you cannot go f5 easily which is very
important yeah Luke h3 that is certainly
a point or an idea but I can always go
g6 or I can play a five both them should
be decent yeah I wonder really g6 or not
it looks fairly safe so let's do it not
totally sure about f5 yeah bishop a six
smile next move pretty much no matter
what
um yeah I was rich in the announcement I
said I'm looking horrible yeah because I
was building that that piece of
furniture and I was sweating like a new
tomorrow and totally done so i really am
I really wanted to take a shower and
everything before i go on video but it
didn't manage him i'm basically coming
back from my um from a bedroom after
having completed that they'd build off
of that thing okay now it would it gets
sharp him but I get the night 24 which
is fantastic but my dark squares are
really really really bad so I hope that
I don't think that this is so dangerous
actually yes he has lots of problems as
well taking here for example whole arm I
wonder if I'm actually having something
even better be sure 1 f 6 is not really
threatening much only after Queen g for
later but i have 9 f 2 okay i'm going to
take here i don't think this can be can
be wrong it can be it can be wrong for
sure but i don't think so really so let
this for Queen Queen somewhere and rupee
one yes but what are you threatening
Bishop f6 i have 9 f 2 and wins so i
don't quite get it
grab this a night f2 is made on the back
rank it's not even just the Queen
yeah rupee one I think my counter check
is pretty substantial and they could
have played h5 by the way I didn't
really didn't really see that first but
I it's not necessary really yeah night
f2 and resides right what is the point
okay there is no checkmate there without
the Queen I was a weird game anyway I
gotta win who so let's try for a new
game and after that I'm going to check
sing for a cup if I'm managing to do
that actually um within blitz and I
always feel like if you like lost you
don't use that interface normally guys
are there any question that you want to
ask i mean the chat is not as busy as
usual so i'm actually probably will be
able to read them all and answer them to
the best of my ability in fact what I
have planned um but I didn't want to do
it today because I wanted some more
announcement time before that I actually
have pled the show on Monday that
doesn't have any games but just
questions and answers so that I would be
fully focused on on on answering
questions also am I would be able to put
stuff on the board yeah like if someone
asked me what is it would line and a no
against the El beans counter gambit or
so and then I can put it on the board
and analyze a little bit um so this is
something that I have planned for for
the future and one question is any
thoughts on Carla's bad shape hmm well
the thing is um we are so used to him
being um to him being basically playing
immaculate that that it feels weird that
all of a sudden he's able to make
mistakes him and aunt is he's just human
it seems and maybe this is very very
reassuring for all of us that is not
just a chess-playing robots but still a
human being um I think him it's hard to
tell what exactly is going on there um
maybe something
I would have chess related that's always
possible that something is distracting
distracting him a little bit here that
that could be and and yeah maybe people
a little bit less afraid that that's
certainly possible um okay what is this
I mean that is really strange maybe this
I don't know so um questions anyone in
the scenery I'm not supporting anyone in
particular in the sink filled cup um I
think what I really like to see is levon
aronian having a good event because he's
really an excellent player and he had a
really rough time recent month so I
really hope he does well I'm starting to
Madras I massage place is suing against
before I problem with the Grand Prix how
to handle the grand prix with black hmm
job just called for the main line but it
depends a little bit what you play on
move to yeah like a 4c 593 if you play
on move to d6 or e6 or a 6 is a huge
difference so um that's a little bit
hard to tell in that game by the way
that I'm playing a black has some issues
yeah yes whose ceases to sacrifice a
heavily already so I'm going to take
that bishop I think it was lost anyway
so he's giving it up wow he's giving me
yet another piece I understand that I
have no development but it still feels
kind of cool that he gives me another
piece takes on c6 what is the point 94
or something anyway I mean I'm grabbing
stuff if he's checkmating me brilliantly
or all the power to him so Knight f3 I
guess
yeah to f4 that is also possible after
that d5 is good that's true then the
question what's the best way to go over
game collection books with a notation
first play over the games by yourself
and then only go over the game looking
at annotations I think you can look at
the annotations right away and it
sometimes a good idea if you have such a
game collection he resigned actually
didn't even try to throw more do it at
me but it's really just two pieces
there's no check this part is especially
annoying okay next game and ideas if you
look at game collections to sometimes
really put it on a real chess board yeah
not just do it on a screen or something
sit down and take your favorite
non-alcoholic beverage I guess I colic I
don't know and and club play over the
games and dumb that makes them then make
sense there's a question why Sicilian
dragon variation so sharp and it is and
is it solid and if so why isn't it
played on top level that much hmm I mean
I wouldn't call the Dragons solid um the
problem with the dragon on the top level
is that while the top guys no no the
stuff really well and white has has
lines one or two lines where black is
really just fighting for equality and
cannot ever win it's very M it is rather
one-sided like is ok but it's nothing
very exciting for him but this is why
people don't play it that much cadd9 can
on move nine castles d5 ism a little bit
stale yeah gachinco says there's a 4c
593 place d 6 or move to if you play why
do you play to d6 do we go for the night
off if you go for the night off play a
six then you can prevent the Grand Prix
all together
you falsified maybe we get it on the
board no we don't now can this tab let
me decline the Smith Maura with d3 this
is my usual recipe we actually allow us
this that's surprising it's usually
quite nice for black to get rid of that
bishop yeah I'm satisfied that this is a
very decent maroc see bind type of game
type of position I'm sorry 94 instead
making any sense yeah maybe maybe sort
of the maroc see bind is comfortable
against the dragon um yeah well if
you'll get can get it in it sure is but
in the dragon proper not the accelerated
dragon you don't get amarok see point
okay here someone asked if I still get
dislikes from people from Latvia my
videos mmm yeah I don't know I didn't it
didn't check recently if Wally gas is
still disliking my videos hmm okay what
is this here okay I go away six that is
not a very stable peace so he now really
removes that bishop it was to be
expected yeah I wonder if he five as a
move it's interesting let's try it it's
probably a bit questionable but it's
it's it's it's interesting to try out
now I have this very nice control
already 40 really
you knows this point TX bishop age 6 mm
I don't know if that makes much sense
okay I'm taking with the with the night
which should be to classical against the
dragon is a pretty a pretty solid line
it's not not so bad mm no I won't play
the Latvian gambit what is blacks goal
in this position get in b5 is a question
hmm yeah I mean one one thing is that in
this position um I'm pretty okay as it
is I mean it's not like I have a good
night on default and just sitting there
wouldn't be wouldn't be terrible it's
got f5 as an idea that is a bit of a
nuisance I would love to trade dark
squared bishop of course hmm I wonder if
there's some way to to do that okay
let's play a waiting move and see I'm
not sure if be five is any good f5 is
interesting when it's that's probably
probably not really working
it's a risky move yeah so some people
say this is my video on the my channel
the refutation of the Latvian gambit and
some some people say like I refuted let
me get me that's funny I mean that the
opening I didn't do anything besides
checking what is best I didn't refute it
like I didn't find anything great or so
it's just what what what you will see if
you have have a look at it once um how
do you master end games when you are
beginner is it more practice or theory
um oh that's a difficult question um I
mean your practice end games basically
all the time by playing game so you
would you have end games rather often in
blitz chance and all kinds of time
controls um and you what you have to
practice and learn this you have to
practice and learn a couple really just
a couple not not a ton of theoretical
end games and games that can be learned
by heart and then you have to get more
accustomed to to end game strategy ideas
how to handle an end game well and this
is something where um you you have some
options to do that i'm looking at study
master games ss11 very decent option but
it's not the only one you can also look
at some books that that can be helpful
um so what is this actually I wonder if
I can take on f5 that looks around the
risky but I don't know now can I go look
g8 and do something on the G file maybe
this is totally too optimistic but I'm a
natural optimist in chess yeah I could
have gone before to clamp down on the
queenside but there was too much going
on the center of hell
I'm somewhat Donald on time every don't
know boy did I spend so much time on I
think the position is okay yeah someone
mentioned that the GUI shook is down to
28 minutes for 22 move that that sounds
rather comfortable I mean compared to
what he often has analysis it feels
rather okay one thing that is not
helping him is that he still is smoking
it has to spend time on that I quite
often now so I'm smoking during during
events when I was playing a European
club cup for example he was always
smoking so what is this a seven coming
hmm am I ready to slow yeah that would
be terrible it looks a little bit like
it ok I have to distract that Queen and
go from there after Queen cheeks what am
I playing I hope she ate mmm that's not
really threatening anything
Queens you five and i have seven hangs I
shoot what the heck I'm not threatening
anything if absolutely nothing you can
just go a seven wow what did I do
yeah amazing how this went down hill you
can just promote I think I can can check
it and play Queen d2 ok so that's not
why is God f6 sad winning probably it is
it is completely unnecessary to play
that complicated but it will win em I
can run up here but I'm going to get
made it anyway wow just check on the
seventh will win that probably as well
he's playing it terribly but it is it is
winning anyway it's just too bad
threatening made on g2 actually what are
you doing now I mean something will win
but probably 55 or something like that
will win I don't know
Butchie one queen d 3 4 830 that's
covering that's covering it okay now
then that's the end of it I made it
super complicated instead of winning
easily um okay um yeah not basic end
games are always recommend data via book
100 end games you must know I like that
that's a question do I think as far off
could outdrink Putin um Dragic says will
it be in a video slide one twitch that's
funny I playing a pure pure chess legend
if you have Guinea wash you cough it's
playing III come on Vasek office 80
years old or something around 80 and
still a very strong GM but it seems that
that he wants to play funny openings
what the heck ok I just played b6 yeah
it's not not that bad yeah I think white
for y termine has got some some center
yeah and this Kasparov even drink that's
exactly the point um cuz five probably
doesn't drink at all you always struck
me as some struck me as a more health
not then someone drinking it's a it's a
typical thing that you believe that the
Russians would they all would drink and
then that's not true really it's a it's
not a slower and I'm slow it's not a low
percentage of Russian Russians that
drink but not all of them really not all
of them when i played in the in the
german leak
we had a couple of people from Russia
and other former Soviet countries and
they they didn't drink at all yeah I
know we can go g6 but I think that d5
must be tremendous compensation g4 I
mean sorry yeah that's just a just good
compensation from black I'm just giving
that yeah your germs and FBI oh I mean
really we have a user be a consumption
per person but I'm probably lowering
that average if I do drink beards it's
mostly non-alcoholic stuff um it's both
interesting let's do it like that i'm
not quite sure oh wait i can take with
the queen that could be interesting now
it's probably good it's not just
interesting 94 queen d4s probably good
idea there's c3 hanging and queen age
for check here I can check on on f3
right yep let's just lying down fog
whose take then ask questions so um okay
I don't want to trade Queens ready do I
have to maybe we have three f3m i have
three pieces for the am sorry three
pawns for the piece so that is that is
good
to go back there it's okay I would have
liked to keep Queens all of course to
harass his King a little bit more but it
didn't didn't work out who do you think
will win the World Cup um impossible to
say the world cup in Chesser is a is
hugely dependent on the rapid games and
I'm not saying everybody can win but
many many people can win who will win
the who are hopeful win um um I don't
have like a sentimental favorite or
something I think it would be very
interesting if ye would win that thing
and qualify for the candidates he really
seems to be exceptionally promising and
this is the only way for him to get to
the candidates i think someone says can
i play Kings Indian attack with one
night of three yeah I can do next next
game um the only thing is I might forget
that i had this intention that happens
quite often in blitz chess I have a very
bad bishop one age eight but I couldn't
really I don't really see how I could
have avoided that um so what now mmhmm
yeah I would love F five but I don't see
how I can do that g5 pawn takes f5 is an
idea actually or is that crazy head is a
bit crazy anyway let's see if I can do
that it gets spawns rolling his rating
is relatively low at the moment he is
normally a bit higher rated in five
minute he really is a very decent blitz
player i vas you cough he was a super
strong blitz play in his in his youth
having a constant duels against the the
all-time greats yeah like a Petrosian
and Spassky and to those those guys in
of course they also in longer time
control chess but also in blitz so what
is this 27 what do you [ __ ] go to d
593 is checkmate huh ok not to d5 ok
let's go here then cover c7
if I somehow get this Bishop activated
yeah I don't know how but it's somehow
I'm not in its not is this play this is
visibly play I'm not not in bad shape
when someone says do you think that
unknown is going to retire in the near
future no I don't think so if he would
have wanted that he probably yeah I mean
it's something that he would have done
already let's say let's put it that way
it seems that he just enjoys the game
enjoy some the whole thing so I don't
see him retiring anytime soon and why
would he is he's really in doing going
going strong it's playing very strong
chest
97 is cool wow just attacking you six
that would have been strong actually
would have been strong move okay I
really have to get my paws rolling
rolling rolling rolling yeah there's
really no reason for honor to retire if
he's got fun playing why why would him
and he's really allowing mima to push
their pants quite far up the board a
[ __ ] I'm a bit mystified so g3 now what
it's 23 after echeck King f1 G to check
read sets promotion that that promotes
come on
that will promote stuff that is these
points are too dangerous I don't believe
in that I think they just promote king
ave 1g2 checking f2 III check and that's
it this one here someone says crown
League will retire before honored and I
don't know but it seems relatively
likely we not that it happens in the
nearest future of it in comparison i
rather see Kramnik retiring them and
then wishing okay that was a was a
window um let me do one thing can I
actually I'm trying this now I'm not
sure if it's working but well it's a bit
screwed up wait
okay that didn't work let's have a quick
life look at the same field cup this is
kiwana with white against Carlton okay
we're coming from a slowish rui
interesting cousins got the bishop
parent some nice center why it is still
very solid though now i think black is
okay I'd rather I'd rather be black here
but it's probably about equal so what
else do we have to pawn off Nakamura
whoa what is this Knight takes is six ok
six I really have to get that first
white has two bishops against two nights
it's equal material or why does a
fantastic position here what is the
power of doing them he's really playing
very successfully at the moment
throughout some slow Berlin ok so we
have my money's on the pile of to win
that sorry for the slight problems with
the warts but I'm glad to have get that
that working at all so what is this
analyst upon down whoa why is why is
that it was from defo fish before
library shook six pawns why does a pawn
up but he has said some what we had rock
on a six black and Scott Lucas e8 coming
hmm
I got feeling us that black is ok but I
don't know Paul is important of course
in the end game but rook c8 hooks it to
look some yeah it means something Oh an
end game that's early opposite colored
bishops and five pawns
okay there will be a draw sometimes it
is already a draw ok and ok they already
agreed to a draw and this year is also
agreed to her already ok so we've got a
couple of games finished and yeah well
Carlton kawana or corona cousin is kind
of equal ish and to Palo seems to seems
to be almost winning against Nakamura
and what was the other game at the Vichy
game yeah I don't know what that was yep
yeah that two draws already so this will
be an old Indian oh I Kings anyin so be
transposed to the King linnean
hmm yeah blacks black setup here is some
it's not particularly good but it is um
I forgot to play 9 a-3 as I announced
okay I'm playing it next time I
definitely will play another white game
so I'm going for that am I really
getting the typical clamp here with g
five people released allow that no that
guy didn't but I think why this is ok
anyway night over 2g three years my idea
how is closing things that's cool the
birds opening no i don't i really don't
play that it's the bird opening not
Birds opening actually so what does he
try to do here i will double on the age
file
yeah why this right is in good shape
here yeah this is this is just pseudo
active it doesn't do anything let's
let's see how to continue here night / 2
2 a 2 h 3 maybe or something hmm i don't
have a direct win can't even do this a
bird opening school I don't know why
what is cool about it gives a like a
quality on move one so what is this idea
does he want to sacrifice somewhere here
maybe he wants hmm yeah I don't know
okay maybe I know that's a bad idea then
it takes on a 3 mm okay yeah okay I'm
readjusting him going over to the Queen
side
so let's see I never played this guy Ken
Starr
I mean the bird opening 1 F for it is
not like completely terrible it just it
just doesn't promise anything having an
extra tempo on the Dutch is simply still
equality at the best so yeah it's
difficult to do something substantial
here I have to I mean if he gets in
night h7 and something to trade off that
Bishop it would be quite awkward I don't
know night each seven it is slightly
offered can I would like to also remove
that Ned Bishop but they're for but for
that I have to cover that rook first
night edge seven is a bit annoying
okay I'm doing that I'm not not sure
about it discovering the beef are going
for Queen B 2 yeah I think this is equal
maybe night age 7 Bishop g5 you can try
but I would be surprised if that leads
to anything
ok keeps queens on hmm yeah I don't I
cannot really invade unfortunately more
interesting Knight to f4 ok
um I don't know that's interesting I'm
don't mind trading the light squared
Bishop seer I don't know what is this it
is it good fam I really don't know it's
interesting Bishop g5 now or what
exactly check here I go to see tool hmm
I don't know I didn't watch the [ __ ] and
to look a little bit at this game I was
irritated by anybody what happened so
where can we take on age 5 huh just do
this ma five Wow jigglin Queen f7 aw
yeah maybe
now my queen is a bit awkward I have to
admit that in relation to the Kings side
is really awkward but maybe Queen see
one now consume one is actually
interesting I could have done that
instead of 92 we would have been would
have been very interesting
I don't understand this what is he doing
Queen f7 Queen f3r what is the point
don't really get it Queen here Quincy
one
I also have that check I mean you cannot
even go to g4 or something I can just
check on c7 okay I don't understand
anything here I know he's covered that
ah wow that was the most stupid laws
ever black it's just worse in this
position here i can i mean i have a
check ever perpetual in hand and I can
try you're taking on d6 or an age 6 or
whatever and I just play Quincy aid ah
ok so that was my queen blunder of that
broadcast ok let's go forward Sicilian
so I don't even know what my way place
here and wow Bishop g5 what the heck ok
Bishop c5 he will take on g7 I guess Wow
ok
mmm interesting that's that's an
interesting way to play what he what he
tried here the night c4 is quite a bit
quite a bit of a nuisance whoa yeah
normally acquainted is free trade is
good for black in the Sicilian but I
don't know about this particular
situation here
night suffice Yuri a real issue
that's very ugly wow wow that's very
ugly it should be 5 10 maybe I have to
play of six just win that porn but I
wanted to play a normal move Queen B 6
why not d 6 yeah because of night see
form yeah my development is not good I
know now maybe it's still rather solid
yeah andy sixx Nazi 45 9 p-6 I don't
believe in that I couldn't go do 6i
believe I mean maybe there was some some
tactical justification but normal moves
certainly not hmm
yeah talk about an ugly position
at least he's seeing some time that's
good yeah i mean just Knight f3 or 9p 3s
just it's just go down taking it is also
not bad no meat no maybe c4 still 9 p-3
it will be better better for while I
don't think I would have taken but it's
not bad okay let's develop
yeah my way that's a good player is
playing an on theoretical openings but
on non theoretical I mean less explored
openings but he's playing well so there
should be six is getting more and more
ugly okay yeah not that this is
beautiful but someone else if I sign
chest sports well maybe drop me a mail
or something for that idea someone says
hard to hear you is it is it that that
that lower the sound the first person
said that why King b7 yeah what what
what more should have play I mean there
should be six for the big threat and now
I'm intending bishop d 6 i'm not sure
how bad it is i think the idea
especially 6 I want to get out of that
out of that pin on the e-file Bishop f5
mm-hmm at the end you will have the
check their g6 looks around at our
Bishop d6 shrimp sea and
and the entire group she ain't it should
work actually unless I'm completely
screwing things up oh I didn't see that
off I no wonder after that day so let's
do this
wow yeah g6 was maybe better in
comparison it's probably the case the
only thing that you can always hope for
is some kind of rook endgame but
probably not going to happen I can take
and King de to that should be fairly
easy King get towards easy now I don't
have anything to coverage seven
and rookie to with some kind of counter
player he loves that okay I mean okay
that's not bad yeah so white but I
thought you can just play King you too
and have a very easy life I don't know
who won t call Tia snow on a sec I'm
threatening something checkmate I'm
actually happy about this position
relatively speaking it really was worse
rook be one is almost horse made
chik-chik snow made unfortunately night
to see you see forever would be kind of
interesting they are there in twenty six
maybe it really looks like there could
be some kind of trickery going on check
okay I'm I didn't see that that's
embarrassing probably just King be six
winning
hmm that's not not that easy actually
here now this okay it's got one second
okay i'm offering the draw here can you
take it no didn't take it um so let's do
one more game I promise the Kings Indian
attack so I will do that are there any
new video movies that you're looking
forward to seeing Wow I'm not not really
following that at the moment what
happens movie wise I think what I
personally find really annoying a little
bit is that there are so many sequels
and prequels and and and I don't know
superhero movies and all kinds of blends
into one another it's not so much
original things going on at least from
what I can tell when Tony I don't really
not really interested in I don't know i
did i see Kingsman no it's really been a
while since i've been been to the movies
I mean what I definitely will see will
be the Quentin Tarantino movie hateful
eight but other than that i'm unsure yes
there's one sacrifice the Fisher movie
that's certainly something that probably
should be seen okay I'm just pushing
stuff here against za room something
didn't calculate if I very much but it
seems like the way to go um but now how
do I get something going here on the
dark squares night b3 is a bit of a
problem actually
hmm okay
yeah i'm giving a pawn but i hope that
the dark squares will be interesting
yeah Tobey Maguire's playing Bobby
Fischer that's a funny idea right but I
think he looks pretty convincing in the
pictures at least and the leaf Liev
Schreiber's the name right um who plays
Spassky really looks like Spassky a lot
I mean okay you don't need to look
exactly like a person to play in but it
helps I mean I couldn't play Gandhi you
know and this guy justice blundered his
queen so I'm going to take the Queen
let's see what's my opinion about the
Dutch you mean the Dutch people or the
Dutch opening probably the Dutch opening
right yep interesting if you want to
fight in every game of the Duchess
they'll bring for you not bad I don't
think Tobey Maguire's particularly poor
actor not not particularly I mean I
don't really see him playing them the
most demanding roles maybe but he's not
awful I've served certainly worse um I
don't get this here really
just taking stuff iam I look it to where
that that is said yeah and Quincy five I
didn't really pay attention i have to
admit after I've won the Queen I kind of
didn't look and that was a mistake it's
a bit awful rookie to mad anyway
I mean I have Bishop h6 Queen f6 the
Lucian defense is an ok chess movie yes
I think it's pretty ok certainly worse
night move was terrible with Christopher
long bear that was that was really
absolutely awful so and what is this
actually it's got night night and
something lined night and porn and
rookie that's not so bad I mean you
blundered that Queen but things could
have been worse the night is still not
really playing
yeah you don't need to have to have many
facial expressions as an actor I mean
the most successful German actor
nowadays has no facial expressions I
mean successful in terms of in terms of
the ticket sales not in terms of quality
the best german-speaking actor at least
would be crystal vaults maybe and he
really knows what he's doing and what
the heck is going on here I don't get if
i take here why is this not winning why
is this not winning tell me I'm a
blundering the Queen again or something
Christoph Waltz is not German anyway
it's the Austrian but German speaking at
least the most successful German actors
til schweiger and he cannot act at all
which opinion you support political
Russia or USA I don't really want what
what I don't really get that question um
opinion about what exactly now I mean I
rather take a relatively democratic
system like the United States that has
obvious flaws then a system that in
itself is not democratic as it is in
Russia you know so um it's um it's kind
of I mean bosa both countries and
systems have their floor certainly but
this is some this is with with all
countries so I won that final game
actually he resigned and I didn't really
get a Kings Indian attack going because
I still didn't I still forgot to get
okay guys I made a pretty decent showing
here for being exceptionally tired and
yeah that's it that was the show what is
there what's your opinion on gear is
attitude what does Geary's attitude is
there something particular about him I
did not recognize it seems outspoken but
nothing out of the ordinary I think ok
guys thanks for watching I'm going to
watch a little bit of sync your comp
later tonight but first I really have to
finish my my furniture building and
still have some shelf to build up ah ok
until next time guys next week bye